et aussi un certain moment les jeans la
confection de jean en vous le savez le
jean a pris un sérieux coup derrière les
oreilles depuis quelques temps de ligne
est plus tout à fait à la mode et cette
conception qui peut soixante huitard de
se vêtir ma foi n'est plus du tout de
mise
à tel point que les confectionneurs de
la région de castelnaudary ont dû
recourir à beaucoup d'astuces
publicitaire ma foi ça pas marcher tout
à fait comme il le souhaitait et à
castelnaudary comme ailleurs le chic à
changer de look
le reportage de fer pas pu lui
oui le jean se vend moins le mythe de
l'amérique se déchire une quinzaine
d'usinés fermées aux etats-unis le
marché s'est rétréci de 20% en deux ans
la france n'est pas épargnée chute des
ventes de 6 à 8% cette année nous idole
n'en portent plus ces 10 16 le premier
français 12000 pantalon par jour peut
être il ya cinq ans 90% de son chiffre
d'affaires avec le moo-jin aujourd'hui
30% seulement ils ne résistent pas au
phénomène de société
ici plus yann
c'est certain que de vivre avec son
temps ce permet de mieux comprendre et
de proposer des produits bancaires
donc vous n'êtes pas un chef
d'entreprise en gare on essaye de la
planète se battre se battre encore se
reconvertir vendre plus créer un style
le gym ce n'est pas morte mais là plus
d'image
la pub délire pour lui en retrouver une
mais sans rien bouleversé toujours les
mêmes archétypes celis est légitime de
la route
l'image du traditionnel de la deuxième
pause naturelles ou de l' aventure
libido débridée a du mal à survivre
la publicité ne fait pas la mode
on ne serait plus sur le jean regarde
actuellement que je pense que l'on dise
n'a eu des délais c'est tout alors s'il
ya un revirement dans la mode et une
baisse la vente l'histoire toute
sépulture retiendra la réticence
vis-à-vis du jeans comme la fin d'un
consensus social autour d'un pantalon et
nomen unique dans la longue saga des
comportements vestimentaires mais encore
la lente agonie d'un signe extérieur de
contestation qui aura duré 15 ans sans
avoir trouvé de successeur ys net
l'imagination